is everybody in vehicle
anybody in the vehicle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm trying to get her out now
[Music]
how we doing how many people in the car
are you the only one in the vehicle yes
i am i'm gonna try to get you out i
can't move i can't
my foot
hey they dispatch get fire here
and ems asap
i can't get her out of the car the
driver's side is in clouds
on her foot
[Music]
26
getting off on the river's exit towards
goose creek
i'm going to work on keeping this fire
out
okay i get you out
all right
my foot is stuck
i know i'm working on it
i'm sorry it's collapsed over there can
we get you out
can you move it yeah i can okay
oh i gotta take my shoe off oh okay
please help me yep i got you it's okay i
don't want to die it's okay sweetheart i
got you okay i'm gonna grab your arms
i'm gonna pull
could you pull your feet yeah i can't
okay pull your feet here i gotta take my
shoulder pull your knees to your chest
okay
yes
yes
pull your knees to your chest
all right
i got you i'm gonna pull you back here
okay i'm gonna pull you back here
okay
somebody else nobody else in the vehicle
right ma'am no all right i'm gonna get
my arms in here
away from the car keep coming with me
keep coming with me
nobody else in the vehicle right no okay
let me go check on these other drivers
okay
let me see here
hey they decided we got her out of the
vehicle
just kinda can see breathing